so 6-9 was being critical of Justin
Bieber and ariana grande for using what
are called bundles to sell more records
right right and I guess what a bundle is
you guys correct me if I'm wrong but you
basically say yo if you buy merch
you get a free album with the Mercs but
billboard counts that album as a merch
sale right album sale the album is or if
you buy a ticket to the show you give
away an album etc right and 6-9 was
critical he was like yo it shouldn't
count because they're not actually just
directly buying the album yeah they're
buying that other thing and then you're
counting the album so billboard you
shouldn't count that because the person
is not choosing to buy the album right
it is not the person's choice that makes
them buy the album and I start thinking
that and I go okay well it's not the
person's choice what comes on on the
radio matter of fact what gets played on
the radio I mean we've known for years
is manipulated through connections with
record labels etc so if you don't count
bundles
should we not count any play that isn't
dictated by the consumer radios a little
different because it's supposedly people
calling in and requesting songs and then
if enough if a song gets requested
enough they add it to the rotation so
maybe in that situation if it's a call
and request we do it but still the
amount of people that are forced to
listen to a song that they actually
don't want to maybe shouldn't get
counted the same you said I'm saying
like yeah I don't think uh radio spin is
the same as someone buying it right it's
not a fraction mill affair exactly yes
so what I guess what they've doing is
they break up the difference between a
spin a purchased a purchase album counts
way more than just a stream there's all
these different ways to break it up that
being said the person listen radio is
not making the choice to listen to it
and I'm really curious what if you've
just made it about audience choice and
it's just like you know if the audience
chooses to listen to that [ __ ] song
then that's what we count now that's
where that gets dices though because now
with Spotify you have played
that curate what people choose that's
another pay get paying somebody who runs
the playlist to put my song in
simultaneously so break the play this
thing down mark was talking about that
this week a new radio yeah it is so
break break how it works that I was too
full you have individuals that are just
like private people that are making
playlists that people get on board with
and listen to and then people can follow
the playlist exactly and it won't like
just like a fall an Instagram account or
something like that and then that
playlist will change yep and they'll
update it like if you fall like Hot Rap
2020 it'll just update with the hottest
songs the hottest rap songs of 2020
right and then you also have Spotify
who's doing it as well okay and then
Spotify will hire DJ's to then make
their playlist for them that'll be like
a Spotify official playlist right rap
caviar is one of like the biggest rap
playlist that spawns
sponsored by Spotify and they
blacklisted six nine oh so they don't
have his name or any of his music on the
playlist which then like inevitably
affect his plays significantly right so
if you have millions of people that are
listening to this playlist every day
that's potentially millions of listens
that aren't going to 6:9 exactly and
getting on rap caviar is like a big deal
yeah yeah like you know rappers would be
like yo I got put on rap caviar like
thank you so much whatever so that's
akin to like getting played on hot 97 or
power 105 back in a day yeah where it's
like my song is on Z 100 or whatever
like and there's argument to me that it
might even be bigger because you can
actually track the metrics like you can
actually see oh mike my song has two
views it doesn't go to the radio station
right whereas the radio it gets played
but you know how many [ __ ] I
got a radio Spotify and the whole world
got it so you can actually see oh I got
put on this place and now I have 8
million 10 million 100 million more
listeners interesting so I added why did
he get been a block I think it was after
like the rest as well as like his
allegations like the pedophilia [ __ ]
back in the day clarify those because we
don't want to put the P word on my
[ __ ] a taint so I think when he was
like 17 or he was a minor he was seen in
a video with like a 13 year old it was a
music video and then the girl was kind
of sexualized music video yeah and so
then he got like charges that he I think
he pleaded guilty but he was a minor at
the time right so it's not on his record
right so it's kind of like expunged but
right for whatever reason like people
use that against him
he didn't [ __ ] the girl or anything guy
he's not like making out the girl in
fact she was just sexualized in this
video I think there was his video right
right which is still [ __ ] up it's if
your daughter you don't want that
apparently he didn't know her age
allegedly I just want to put that word
on the [ __ ] and then all the
same so those are the accusations again
right and so is that coupled with his
arrest and like snitching and everything
that they were like yeah we don't want
to associate yes so funny what is even
more snakish from Spotify because they
made the exclusive podcast about him
that uh who was Angela Angie Martinez
Angie Martinez yes yo yes you make an
exclusive podcast about [ __ ] and
black Lesseps oh you make money off him
off the podcast yeah and the reality of
are we blacklisted him yeah well he's on
the platform still he's on Spotify but
they just took him off the Spotify
playlist which is where you're getting
all the views and then for him still to
get a billboard is is impressive a
billboard number when that being said he
bundled his [ __ ] yeah which I get it's
like you got a play game yeah the way is
being played I actually am NOT against a
bundle because someone still has to
shoot it still has to be a real fan like
to me buying the bundle to get the album
that's a super fam right there
you should be able to be compensated for
super fans supporting your art where is
you just being on a playlist you might
not be a super fan of that person you
might just be on this powerful playlist
yeah I feel you but what if and I'm sure
this doesn't have poke holes in it pocos
and what if you just like the merch what
if the merchant is fire and what are the
Marches dumb cheap like a dollar now I'm
getting to play for super cheap and I
sell a piece of merger with it well I
guess it would be you'd get an album by
which still counts but yeah that's a
great point also it could move it really
yeah yeah I'll deliver the whole album
for a dollar
buy this sticker yeah no that's that's a
good point was then I think because of
this bundle situation he actually has
the biggest drop from week one to week
two so he had a number one and then it
dropped all the way down to 37 so I have
a I have something about that I think
that six nine strategy is very similar
to our strategy in the game would stand
up where I don't think he's going for
a longevity with an album right like our
standard strategy is I want to be in
front of you every week here's a new
clip every single week and these clips
will pop some of them will last forever
some of them might fall off but it was
like what's more valuable is having each
clip and pumping up each clip and albums
people like let me put out this great
masterpiece Kendra Persians kind of
Perkins Kendrick Lamar is gonna come out
with a amazing masterpiece of an album
people listen to a few weeks then it
will go away almost like a comedy
special people talk about for a couple
weeks and then will go away right like
Chappelle's thing last week everybody
talked about it nobody talks about
anyone right so I think he recognized
that and he's like oh if I just create
buzz every week or every month a new
song every week or every month I stay
high and I don't waste 12 songs on one
album and then they're done in two weeks
[ __ ] album I think he really I think
I mean is that fair to say
mark what you think about it yeah no I
agree I think his whole strategy is like
just get hype in the moment and keep
chugging away on like like check my
check getting the momentary height and
then he's like jumping from one lily pad
to the next or whatever that uh metaphor
is you know in video games who they keep
bounce the only thing is his strategy of
getting the attention though yep look I
wish it was just the music that spoke
for it so that's the difference between
us right
we rely on content he relies on antics
yeah so all right yeah but imagine you
had jay-z imagine you had a Kendrick
imagine you have one of these
[ __ ] that every month was
putting out up banger of a song there
was just fire and like cool features and
amazing you'd be like oh [ __ ] this is
every single week I get this yeah yeah
like or every single month whatever it
was
that'd be the biggest rapper in the
world hands down yeah I remember when a
good music was doing this good music
Fridays that [ __ ] was fired why you're
having like the lamborghini mercy and
then yeah like it was just banger after
banger after banger that sure was hard
and think about it even to this even to
this day you're going good music did it
yeah
you're not saying the artists yeah
you're like good music was putting it
out and it blew up good music yeah
so especially when you can't tour oh my
god yes can't be on the road like this
is your only way to like build like
continual height that's right because
they can't do big shows yeah you have to
keep the hype going you put out an album
and think about it you put out an album
you're taking that let's say you work on
your album for a month right you're
taking that month and you're taking that
month of brain power and dividing it
into twelve different songs imagine you
just took a month and worked on one song
and then next month work on one so now
you have 12 songs over the year but each
one gets all your brain power yeah each
one you work on all the [ __ ] rhymes
every single I mean it's it's it's
different musically obviously but like
every week when we put out the piece we
are dedicating all our brain power to
that piece we're not making 12 episodes
of this show the rant right in one month
and then spreading them out throughout
the year and if we did they would be
worse it takes every [ __ ] hour that
we put in yeah
to make that [ __ ] good imagine an artist
like Kendrick Lamar and like a real
[ __ ] artist yeah was just one song
hey here's one this is my song this
month but technically you know they kind
of do that because they have like year
or two or three year intervals between
the album job so yeah they are putting
everything into that one song they just
hold it after it's done if that's their
strategy sometimes a guy like easy we'll
just go he's so talented I'll just do it
for a couple releases yeah like rock
musicians used to do that they like
alright let's write let's go in this
house and like live there and write the
album over a month I guess maybe a
Kendrick writes his pieces over a
certain amount of time if he does I
think he also feels like I feel like
there's an artistic like the album has a
storyline through it it all means
something yeah whatever yeah and you
could theoretically do like this year is
about this and then this is the year of
and then you could have your album title
and then it's like a thematic a year
you know once a month you released I
think about that [ __ ] what if you had
each song react to the next song based
on the new information you know about
the world but you still had a
through-line going and all of a sudden
at the end of the year you celled a full
album and you see the connective tissue
that exists between all the songs
that's gonna have you had and it's like
now the album becomes a piece of art in
of itself and there's a reason to
purchase it now you hold the full year
hostage attention who only your oh [ __ ]
Josie dropping a mixtape I think that'd
be kind of fireman if the musicians did
that yeah and then and you know what you
you would body six nine out of here
because the reality is we're into the
antics and these things are so [ __ ]
entertaining but the content is trashed
the reason we're into the antics is
because there's not content right now
imagine someone would talk to your
contact came out with that [ __ ] honestly
music should be better than ever during
quarantine yes you can all record from
home yet a lot of times to enjoy the
music you want to be out ooh
but like artistic music like not some
[ __ ] there oh yeah we need some ballads
yeah Kendrick could probably drop now
and it'll be a perfect on the job but I
really six quit it and you know just
digesting it brings time to go for a
ride can't appreciate it I can't
appreciate a kendrick thing on the first
lesson but like the baby for example his
album just dropped not too long ago and
I should came and went
because bangers but all his clothes like
you need to be outside see the baby it
conscious my performance he's a he's a
like all these ideas to me are creative
even the video that he ended up doing
like a George Floyd performance but the
music video is him and rowdy rich and
they're in like a zombie apocalypse
situation it's like The Walking Dead
he's always got ideas the only thing is
that it's funny because he's also the
baby but lo baby dropped the conscious
one like a week or two and I think he
saw how well that did cause I'm on it
yeah yeah yeah I give more credit to
lobby because he was the first like
major artist to come out with some
conscious [ __ ] you're gonna see a lot of
performative support I think because
people gravitate towards what successful
and it doesn't mean that they don't also
care about the causes but artists
generally are going to replicate what
they see gives them the most you know I
don't know financial success or
potential financial success in the
future
galvanize I don't think you're wrong I
think overall even if that's true I like
the baby and I like the he approaches
his videos in particular with a lot of
creativity like that Broadway Bob [ __ ]
the one take was fire his team real
goats they they're like the this of
music they just be doing some creative
[ __ ] they're always thinking and you
don't like hear their name all the time
in the zeitgeist but that's a team
that's like fine and therefore they be
putting out fire
[Applause]